let's get started welcome to CS 224 you
our topic is natural language
understanding and if you can understand
the words that I am saying right now you
are already pretty good at natural
language understanding this might even
be an easy class for you but you
probably have a device in your pocket
that's not very good at natural language
understanding and that's the problem
that we want to tackle in this class but
first let me introduce myself my name is
bill McCartney I'm an adjunct professor
in the computer science department
adjunct professor basically means
part-time professor I've been teaching
this class for eight years now but my
full-time work is in industry currently
I'm an apple where I help to lead part
of the AI and machine learning
organization I was previously a research
scientist at Google and my focus at
Google was natural language
understanding for search and for the
Google assistant let me also introduce
my co-instructor Chris Potts you want to
say anything okay so Chris and I are
gonna share the teaching
responsibilities today you'll mainly
hear from me and on Wednesday Chris will
take the stage so the first question I
want to look at is why study natural
language understanding what are our
goals in studying natural language
understanding and a few possibilities
come to mind one is that it may yield
insights into human cognition human
language is phenomenally complex and
understanding natural language can be
surprisingly difficult if we can figure
out how to enable machines to understand
language it might help us to understand
how humans understand language so this
amounts to building a model of a
phenomenon in order to understand it
better another goal might be to build
conversational agents that can provide
assistance or
entertainment or companionship so for
example you might want to build a
natural language interface to an airline
reservation system or you might want to
build a toy that can have a conversation
with a child or you might want to build
a virtual companion like in the movie
her another possible goal is that
solving NLU would mean solving a major
subproblem of artificial intelligence
after all you can't really claim that a
system has achieved human level
intelligence if it can't understand
language so NLU is a necessary step on a
path to strong AI so those are a few
possible motivations I'm curious to hear
if you guys have other ideas are there
other motivations that have brought you
to this class why are you interested in
studying NLU there's been an explosion
in the last few years of computational
social science so using computational
methods to gain better insights into
topics that are traditionally not part
of computer science but part of social
science so it's a scientific goal but
it's not aimed at understanding how
humans understand language it's using
NLU as a tool to study something else
any other ideas
like yeah
many of the many of the goals that NLP
has aimed at over the last couple of
decades are comparatively modest goals
so not aimed at actually understanding
language in its fullness but instead
aimed at lower level tasks like tagging
tasks or syntactic analysis or even
translation which is a comparatively
harder and higher-level task but still
fall short of any other thoughts before
I go on hoping older people with
technology through natural language
understanding yeah can you say a little
more about this I just like as people
get older their memory they start to
have no issues talking becomes harder so
having some form of companion and
someone who can understand how to
communicate with you to help better your
condition something like that yeah so
maybe a combination of assistance and
companionship I'm just gonna say you
might be okay yeah so the so that
comment was about providing assistance
and companionship companionship to older
people to help them with their lives and
and help them not feel so alone
great okay let me keep going I think I
skipped a slide oh I was gonna make an
observation first which is that some of
the goals we've talked about are
primarily scientific goals and others
are primarily technological goals so
maybe number one is a scientific goal
number two I would call a technological
goal trying to create a new piece of
technology number three may be ambiguous
between the two but this split between
scientific goals and technological goals
is one that's been a part
NLU for a long time and in fact you see
it in this quote from James Allen who's
the author of one of the earliest texts
on natural language understanding he
says there can be two underlying
motivations for building a computational
theory the technological goal is simply
to build better computers and any
solution that works will be acceptable
the cognitive goal is to build a
computational analog of the human
language processing system such a theory
will be acceptable only after it had
been verified by experiment so the
question is when we build a natural
language understanding system do we care
whether it understands language in the
same way as a human that is using
similar techniques if we're a cognitive
scientists then of course we do care if
we're technologists then we probably
don't we asked you to read this short
paper by Hector Levesque for today and
he makes the same distinction between
scientific goals and technological goals
he points out that in some cases you can
achieve the technological goals of
artificial intelligence through what he
calls cheap Trick's and that pejorative
term makes it clear that what he cares
about are the scientifical it's not the
technological goals in this course we're
going to approach the topic of natural
language understanding primarily from
the technologists perspective but I
think it's useful to keep this other
perspective in mind another important
question for us is what counts as
understanding if we're building a
natural language understanding system
how do we know whether we've succeeded
how do we know whether our system truly
understands over the years many
different criteria have been proposed
one possibility is to say that I
understand a statement if I can specify
its truth conditions so if I'm going to
claim to understand a statement like
every amino acid contains nitrogen then
I need to be able to state what has to
be true in order for that to be so so
this seems like a plausible criterion
for understanding
any reservations about that any anything
wrong with that as a criterion for
understanding yes yeah there's opinions
there's lots of other kinds of
statements that don't really have truth
conditions - like if I say a great
example of an opinion if I say like hey
did you see Saturday Night Live this
weekend it was the funniest thing I've
ever seen
like how would I like you that's
meaningful you understand it you
understand my meaning
but how would I specify the truth
conditions for that's the funniest thing
I ever saw it's hard to imagine any
other thoughts about this as a criterion
of understanding yes emotional or human
condition statements literature yeah if
I say I take a statement like love is
the most important thing in life what
are the truth conditions for that I
wouldn't have the foggiest idea how to
specify the truth conditions for that
and yet it's perfectly meaningful and we
can talk about understanding what that
means another possible criterion is to
say that we understand a statement if we
can calculate its entailments this is
closely related to the first one but
we're shifting our attention from the
conditions of the statement to its
consequences later in the quarter we're
going to look at the task of natural
language inference which is one way of
operationalizing that criterion another
possibility is to say that to understand
a statement is to respond appropriately
to take appropriate action based on the
statement so this might be relevant for
example if you're playing if you're
playing a text-based adventure game like
the kind of game where you want to be
able to type commands like go north or
take gold or stab dwarf or
or you know if you're talking to your
iPhone and you just want to be able to
say set an alarm for 9 p.m.
does it do the right thing does it take
the right action
another possibility another possible
criterion for understanding is to
understand is to be able to translate
into another language this seems like a
high bar for understanding maybe not
maybe not a necessary condition but
perhaps a sufficient condition what do
you guys think if you're building a
natural language understanding system
how will you evaluate whether it
understands how are you how you judge
whether it actually works this question
of evaluation is going to be one that
we're going to look at a lot more
understanding yeah so your suggestion is
that an important test of understanding
is the ability to empathize with the
statement I don't know how we would
operationalize that as a as a measure of
computer understanding of a system but I
think it's a good insight yeah yeah
closely related to take appropriate
action in light of it or respond
appropriately if you had a chatbot
that's trying to maybe almost play the
role of therapist you want to make sure
that your chat bot is responding in a
way that shows real understanding and
real empathy and right now that's a
that's a
pretty high bar a challenge that that
seems pretty pretty far out of reach at
this point yes understanding is to be
able to create a graph that has like
concepts and says notes and then draws
relations and between them you see like
how to sort of like not just like like
find the true thinking would just
understand I guess like what it means
how these different objects interact
with one another just like us a concept
yes so to just I'm just gonna try to
repeat it back build a graph of concepts
and relationships between them based on
that understanding based on the
statement that was given there and in
fact one of the topics that we're gonna
look at this quarter is the topic of
relation extraction which is precisely
about taking a piece of natural language
text like a web page and identifying the
entities that are mentioned in the text
and the relationships between them and
one of the applications for this is to
automatically construct knowledge graphs
from text on the web at scale so that we
can learn about you know the fact that a
certain album came from a certain band
and the band originated in a certain
city and it got started in a certain
year and we can learn all this from some
you know fan page that somebody wrote or
a review or something like that okay so
a bunch of good ideas about criteria for
understanding this question of
understanding has been at the heart of
philosophical debates about artificial
intelligence for many years a quick show
of hands how many people in the room are
familiar with the Turing test okay that
is reassuring I would have been alarmed
if it were not a high proportion how
many people are familiar with Searles
Chinese room argument okay so maybe half
so Turing's position is essentially a
behaviorist position he says that a
system is intelligent if its behavior is
indistinguishable from
of an intelligent human being for our
purposes we might say that a system
truly understands if it behaves as if it
understands
in other words behavior is a behavior
itself is enough to demonstrate
understanding Searle rebutted by saying
that even if a system behaves as if it
understands it might not truly
understand and he asks you to imagine
that you're locked in a room and your
past questions in Chinese through a
little slot in the door and you have to
respond in Chinese and pass the answers
back out through this slot and the
problem is that you don't speak any
Chinese but you have in the room with
you thousands and thousands of books
that specify in exhaustive detail an
algorithm that you can follow to
generate the answers so you're
essentially playing the role of a human
emulator of a Chinese natural language
understanding system now Searles
argument is that by executing this
algorithm you might succeed in fooling
people outside the room that you
understand Chinese but in fact you don't
understand at all he says behavior is
not proof of understanding so what do
you think about this argument do you buy
that is it plausible does it stand up
thoughts on this yeah oh it's a pretty
high bar if it's correct because if you
continue with like our architectures you
always have some tiny little Turing
machine and that's never going to have a
state that fully encapsulated like the
Chinese language or any other
complicated system it's just going to be
traversing a big algorithm
yeah did you see that use the phrase
tangled touring system oh I
misunderstood you okay yes I also feel
like that assumes that like we know what
it means to understand as humans like
following so like it's hard to separate
like the algorithm from but with the
only one understanding he doesn't really
find what understanding is that's right
touring gives tour gives this very
behaviorist definition of what
understanding is he's basically saying
understanding is just behaving as if you
understand
and Cyril robots that but it doesn't
replace it with any other definition of
what constitutes understanding yes also
extrapolate like I'm not that young
they're too old algorithms not that
standard extrapolation yeah as humans we
extrapolate a lot actually can you say a
little bit more about that yeah okay yes
question is how do you define human
understanding are you trying to
supersede to understanding like surpass
human understanding cuz I don't even
know that we understand how human thinks
at moments so yeah so I think what
you're really getting at is is is human
understanding is is the way that human
understands necessarily the goal or
maybe there can be other kinds of
understanding which are not the same as
human understanding but are still
important and valuable and that's a nice
segue to this quote from the eminent
linguist Noam Chomsky he says the
question of whether a computer is
playing chess or doing long division or
trans
in Chinese is like the question of
whether robots can murder or airplanes
can fly blah-blah-blah-blah-blah these
are questions of decision not fact
decision as to whether to adopt a
certain metaphoric extension of common
usage so he basically seems to be saying
that in fact there's no fact of the
matter to debate here it's just a
question of how we choose to talk about
it it's just a question of how we choose
to use the word understand and I think
more and more people feel comfortable
using the word understand to talk about
computers it may not be the same as
human understanding
but we're still okay calling it
understanding and it's still something
which can be valuable and useful and can
help us achieve applications okay of my
philosophy for today you have to indulge
me for a little bit of philosophy at the
beginning of this class as an undergrad
I was actually a philosophy major so I
like to wax a little philosophical now
and then we're gonna turn now from
philosophy to history and here's a
nutshell history of natural language
understanding so in the early days of
computing NLU was front and center
complete precise understanding of human
language was seen as a central goal of
artificial intelligence and there was
actually quite a bit of optimism that it
would soon be achieved and there were
some impressive early successes which
which led to this optimism for example
there was a system called sure glue
which was created by Terry Winograd who
some of you may know he's now a
professor he wasn't then but he is now a
professor here at Stanford ensured Lou
allowed you to have a conversation about
a simplified blocks world but the
systems that were developed at that time
tended to be quite narrow in scope and
their understanding was very brittle so
if you said something one way it might
understand but if you said the same
thing using slightly different words it
might not understand
and would completely fall down in the
1990s came the so called statistical
revolution in NLP and this brought some
important new tools like data and
machine learning but it also brought a
general retreat from the higher-level
ambitions of natural language
understanding and instead the focus
shifted to lower level tasks like part
of speech tagging and syntactic parsing
and things like that and then about 10
years ago we saw this big resurgence of
interest in natural language
understanding now leveraging new machine
learning techniques and vastly greater
computational resources and starting
about five years ago deep learning
methods have completely transformed
natural language understanding so
starting with neural embedding methods
like word Tyvek which is not actually
deep learning but kind of gets bucketed
together with them and then moving on to
things like LST ends and sequence to
sequence models and many other flavors
and now trained on vastly larger data
sets than had ever been available before
and so that means that this is an
incredibly exciting time to be working
in natural language understanding so in
academia there's been this resurgence of
interest after many years in the
wilderness and in the commercial world
there's a growing sense that natural
language understanding is on the verge
of breaking through as a mainstream
technology and over the last few years
there's been an explosion of businesses
and services that are based on natural
language understanding so things like
Siri and the Google assistant and Amazon
Alexa and Microsoft Cortana and
Samsung's bixby and many more and many
people see conversational agents as
being a key battleground between the
tech giants over the coming years and by
the way that means that Stanford grads
with expertise in NLU are in very high
demand so where is the state of the art
today well today's best NLU systems
are sometimes impressive but they have
severe limitations which quickly become
apparent and I'll show you a bunch of
examples of those limitations in a few
minutes and I think what this shows is
that NLU is far from a solved problem
there's still a lot of discoveries
waiting to be made and for me as a
scientist and a technologist that means
that NLU offers this irresistible
combination on the one hand there's a
lot of interest in NLU there's great
demand for it it's ready to make a huge
impact but on the other hand even though
we're making rapid progress like it
still doesn't really work yet and
there's still so there's still a lot of
discoveries that are waiting to be made
there's still a lot of gold in the
ground and that's really exciting one of
the most visible NLU applications today
is Siri the personal assistant on your
iPhone despite growing competition it is
still by far the most used virtual
assistant with half a billion active
users when it first appeared in 2011
some even described it as representing a
breakthrough in artificial intelligence
and as defining the next generation of
interaction design even if you think
that those claims are just a little bit
inflated there's no question that Siri
has been tremendously impactful and over
the last few years we've seen Google and
Amazon and Microsoft and others develop
similar products and add some degree of
natural language understanding not only
to phones but to watches and TVs and
cars and now smart speakers so how do
conversational agents like Siri work
well if the input modality is speech
then we start with automatic speech
recognition and as you probably know the
accuracy of speech recognition systems
has increased dramatically over the last
few years thanks to the application of
neural networks and deep learning
methods you might think based on the
name
that natural language understanding
would include speech recognition but
historically the two fields have been
quite separate and the term NLU is
usually restricted to understanding of
written input that is understanding of
text of course in some use cases the
input is already written or typed so we
can skip the automatic speech
recognition on the output side we often
have a text-to-speech module or TTS
module so that's not NLU either the NLU
component sits in the middle and it's
often surprisingly simplistic we
typically start with pre-processing by
some standard NLP tools such as part of
speech tagging and named entity
recognition and resolution and then the
heart of it is an interpreter that
generates some kind of meaning
representation as output so that's a
machine readable representation of the
semantics of the request and then that
meaning representation is passed to a
service manager which can make calls to
internal and external api's to execute
the request now there's a lot of room
for variation here the meaning
representation can be discrete or it can
be continuous the interpreter can be
manually engineered or it can be learned
from data or most commonly it's some
combination of those two and in this
course we'll take a look at a lot of
those design choices now there are a lot
of interactions that you'd really like
to be able to have which are just beyond
the capabilities of today's
conversational agents so here's an
example dialog you say where as black
panther playing a mountain view and the
agent says black panther is playing at
the century 16 theater when is it
playing there it's playing at 2 p.m. 5
p.m. and 8 p.m. ok I'd like one adult
and two children for the first show how
much would that cost this will be
incredibly useful but it's also
incredibly hard let's take a minute to
dissect exactly what makes this hard and
I'm gonna focus just on one
aspect of understanding here I'm going
to focus just on reference resolution so
this is the problem of understanding
what the various expressions refer to in
order to do that we're going to need a
bunch of knowledge we're going to need
first of all domain knowledge because we
need to figure out that black panther
refers to a movie and Mountain View
refers to a town we also need discourse
knowledge because we need to figure out
that it refers to black panther and
there refers to the century 16 theater
and that refers to the tickets and we're
gonna need world knowledge because we
need to understand that people don't
usually by adults and children so the
user is talking about buying adult and
child tickets and also we need to figure
out that the first show refers to 2 p.m.
because 2 p.m. is before 5 p.m. and 8
p.m. so there's a lot going on here in
what at first glance appears to be a
relatively simple dialogue there's a lot
of different kinds of knowledge that we
need to bring to bear in order to
execute this conversation successfully
so just for fun let's see how Syriac
Chua Lee does with this dialogue in real
life so these are some screenshots that
I captured last year when Black Panther
came out and I'm gonna try to recreate
the interaction that we had on the
previous screen and we'll see how Siri
does with this so I start off by saying
where does Black Panther playing in
Mountain View and Siri says here's black
panther playing at 9 theaters in
Mountain View ok so Siri definitely
understood what I wanted that's great
Rauf to a good start
you know you might quibble that the
first result is actually in Saratoga and
the second result is actually in
Cupertino and the third result I'm not
sure where that is but we have to go all
the way down to like number 5 or 6
before we get to one that I'm pretty
sure is in Mountain View so you know I
might quibble about that but all in all
I think it's a pretty promising start
that we're off to now I'm going to try
to
continue the dialogue from the previous
slide so I say when is it playing there
you might think my question is kind of
stupid because Siri already gave me the
show times and I guess I failed to read
them or something so okay I'm a bad user
I'm an idiot but my claim is that Siri
ought to be able to do something useful
with this even if I'm an idiot
I think Siri ought to be able to make
some sense of this a human would be able
to make sense of this right if you had a
human he won't be like oh yeah he's a
dumb user but I'm gonna give him the
answer anyway when is it playing there I
think you ought to be you ought to be
able to interpret that as referring to
maybe the first result that you gave me
and so maybe give me the show times for
the AMC Saratoga let's see if that's
what Siri done so he says here are some
movies playing at theaters near you I
don't have the feeling that Siri really
understood what I was asking for it
didn't give me showtimes for the first
result it didn't give me well I guess it
did give me some some show times but I
don't feel like Siri really understood
me at all I feel like this conversation
is kind of going off the rails let's
forge ahead though and see what happens
with the hardest part okay I'd like one
adult and two children for the first
show how much would that cost
now again I'm just following the script
from the previous slide and maybe I'm an
idiot but I think Syria ought to be able
to interpret this as referring to I mean
I said the first show so I guess maybe
that's this one or maybe it's this one
or something I want to buy some tickets
and I want Siri to understand that I
want to buy some tickets Siri says
here's what I found in the web for okay
I'd like one adult and two children for
the first show how much would that cost
have a look and it gives me some results
about how much I should spend on
groceries and when should a child be
taken from his parents
it seems a little odd it's interesting
though series fallback strategy when it
doesn't understand I mean it it has to
do something right it can't just like
raise an exception and print a stack
trace it it has to do something
so it's fallback strategy is it takes
the last thing it thinks you said and it
searches the web for it and you know as
a fallback strategy that doesn't seem
like the worst idea I'm really not
trying to make fun of Siri my point is
to illustrate just how hard NLU is by
the way I tried the very same
interaction with the Google assistant
and it didn't do any better it was
pretty much the same kind of outcome
besides I don't need to make fun of Siri
because people much funnier than me have
already done the job for example Stephen
Colbert so this is from when Siri first
came out in 2011 I'm not going to try to
play the clip but I put the URL and I'm
gonna post these slides so that you can
go check it out later if you want to
colbert explains that he's been playing
with his new iphone 4 all day and so he
didn't get around to writing the show so
he wants siri to write the show for him
because like series magical right it'll
just work so he says to siri write the
show and siri says what would you like
to search for and he says i don't want
to search for anything i want to write
the show and Siri says searching the web
for search for anything I want to write
the shuffle so you see this fallback
strategy again of searching the web and
again you get the impression that Siri
didn't really understand what he was
asking for now in this case maybe it's
forgivable because you know his meaning
was complex he wasn't just asking to set
an alarm but it's kind of interesting to
see the same the same fallback strategy
and then I love this a few minutes later
he says for the love of God give me
something know for the love of God the
cameras are on give me something
and Siri says what kind of place are you
looking for camera stores or churches so
this is very revealing I think what's
happening here is that Siri has like
latched on to cameras and God and then
it's like an eager puppy that just wants
to go search the web for you and then a
little bit later he says fu and Siri
says I blush if I could so this this
fallback strategy is very reminiscent of
Eliza do you guys know about Eliza so
Eliza is this very famous program from
the 1960s it was one of the first
programs that at least appeared to be
doing natural language understanding
Eliza is basically a chat bot that
assumes the role of a psychiatrist and
at first the dialogue seems to be
surprisingly natural and lifelike and in
fact some of the early users have
apparently found it so convincing that
they asked to be alone in the room with
a therapist but if you're a slightly
more discriminating observer you soon
realize that it's just reacting to
triggers in what you say it's just
matching patterns and then transforming
the patterns in some way so if I say X
then Eliza says why do you think X or
does it please you to believe that X now
it does demonstrate at least a little
bit of linguistic capability so for
example it knows how to swap the first
and second person when reformulating X
but this is only the shallowest
imitation of understanding it's not the
real deal it's what Hector Levesque
would call a cheap trick
as you probably know Nou has become a
major priority at Google it was my focus
when I was at Google and one reason for
that is that more and more search
activity is shifting to mobile devices
and more and more queries are spoken
rather than typed and it turns out that
when people talk to their phones they're
much more likely to use natural language
than when they're typing into a search
box so Google has made a big push on
what's known as conversational search
and a big part of making that work is
understanding the context of the
conversation so instead of a bunch of
isolated queries you can have a coherent
conversation and you can refer back to
stuff that was mentioned earlier so you
can ask about Chicago and then you can
say who's the mayor and Google knows
that you're talking about the mayor of
Chicago and then you can say how old is
he who is he married to and Google knows
what you're talking about or you can ask
about the San Diego Zoo and you can say
is it open how far is it call them of
course it doesn't always work perfectly
getting this stuff right is remarkably
hard but more and more it actually works
actually semantic interpretation is not
just for natural language queries it's
also increasingly important for queries
that aren't natural language but are
more like what you might call Google
isse whether spoken or typed into a
search box that's because a growing
proportion of the query stream is not
well served by traditional keyword based
information retrieval more and more
queries are seeking answers that are not
found on any web page so consider
something like how to bike to my office
there's not a web page that I there's
not a like static ordinary web page that
I can give back that's going to give you
the answer to that and more and more
queries are seeking action rather than
information so something like text my
wife I'm on my way just imagine if
Google responded to queries like these
by giving you 10 blue links to documents
containing those terms I mean that might
work okay for this one I don't know I
haven't tried it it might work okay for
this one it's definitely not gonna give
you a satisfactory result for this one
right that's going to be a really bad
user experience satisfying queries like
these requires semantic parsing which
means mapping the query into a
structured machine readable
representation of meaning that can be
passed to some downstream comp some
back-end component to take action on and
I've shown some examples of what
semantic representations might look like
here but I'm not going to dwell on this
now this is a topic that we'll return to
in a couple of weeks
another big application for NLU is
sentiment analysis and growth in this
area has been driven by the explosion of
user-generated content on the Internet
so this basically means looking at
product reviews and social media and
trying to understand how people feel
about companies and brands and products
and which specific features of products
they like and dislike there are zillions
of startups that are that are operating
in this space and they're pursuing a
variety of different business models so
for example there are so called market
analytics firms that do sentiment
analysis on social media and product
reviews and then sell the results to
marketers to help them understand how
consumers feel about their products and
apparently if you're an airline the
answer is they hate you with every fiber
of their being another intriguing
application for sentiment analysis has
been in quantitative finance as an
example there was a paper that came out
a few years ago that claimed to use
analysis of sentiment on Twitter to
predict moves in the Dow Jones
Industrial Average up to six days in
advance with 87 percent accuracy that
sounded pretty awesome pretty exciting
so
a couple of guys started a hedge fund to
trade this idea the fund was massively
over oversubscribed they quickly raised
a hundred million dollars to try to
exploit this idea unfortunately the
methodology was completely bogus and the
hedge fund soon had to shut down but
just because this idea didn't work
doesn't mean there's nothing there and
in fact many asset managers are now
using natural language understanding
techniques in automated trading of
course the shops that are using these
techniques are extremely cagey about
about how they're doing what they're
doing so it's hard to know for sure how
prevalent this is but if you look
closely you can see lots of signs of
automated trading being driven by text
analysis for example a few years ago a
blogger named Dan Mirvish noticed that
every time Anne Hathaway was in the news
there was a jump in the stock price of
Berkshire Hathaway
the holding company run by Warren
Buffett nobody knows knows for sure but
it seems plausible that some automated
trading system was confusing the actress
with the holding company so some NLU
systems demonstrate very limited
understanding nevertheless this is a
fast-growing area these days most
trading is automated and most trading
strategies rely in part on automated
analysis of unstructured feed
unstructured data feeds so that means
natural language text that means things
like news stories and broker reports and
SEC filings and transcripts of
conference calls and social media and so
on it turns out that you can make
enormous trading profits if you can
discover and act on market making news
just a little bit faster and more
accurately than your rivals so you know
things like Disney's acquisition of 21st
Century Fox or Trump's summit with Kim
falling apart essentially they're using
natural language understanding to
predict the markets
actually it's when things go wrong that
the use of NLU in automated trading
systems becomes most apparent and there
was a very interesting example in 2008
involving United Airlines stock so what
happened is Google News crawled the
Florida Sun sentinels website and they
found a story about United Airlines
filing for bankruptcy so they began
serving it up on Google News automated
trading systems began to react within
seconds and this triggered an avalanche
of stock sales within 12 minutes more
than a billion dollars in stock market
value had evaporated and that's this
huge cliff here in this price chart the
problem was the story was six years old
it was from 2002 for some reason the
newspaper had posted this old story in
their popular news section and the only
date on the article was September 7th
2008 so it was the day before this thing
happened so finger-pointing all around
the newspaper should have dated their
article properly Google should have
recognized that the story was a
duplicate of a story from 6 years old
before you know from 6 years ago
and above all automated trading systems
shouldn't believe everything they read
there was an even more dramatic example
in 2013 you might remember this one
somebody hacked The Associated Press
Twitter feed to report explosions at the
White House and Obama injured so instant
pandemonium the Dow immediately plunged
more than 140 points and then recovered
within just six minutes because look
look at the size of this spike here this
is incredible because this affected the
entire market and not just a single
stock the impact of it was much bigger
the sp500 temporarily lost 136 billion
dollars in market capitalization now you
might say oh but it came right back up
so no big deal right but the people who
bought on the way up were not
necessarily the same
as the people who sold on the way down
chances are there were some huge winners
and some huge losers from this event and
this was again very likely driven by
automated trading systems here's a quote
from some dude who says that just goes
to show you how algorithms read
headlines and create these automatic
orders you don't even have time to react
as a human being so there are tremendous
economic incentives to improve the
accuracy and the reliability of these
NLU systems and banks and hedge funds
are making big investments in this area
okay so that was kind of a whirlwind
tour of a bunch of real world commercial
applications of NLU with particular
emphasis on limitations of NLU there's a
lot of stuff that's still not really
possible or still goes wrong with NLU
and for us that represents a big
opportunity to make new discoveries and
find better ways of doing things
enough about applications how are we
going to approach this topic and all you
is a big field it covers many different
subtopics so how can we organize the
content of the field one way to organize
the subtopics is into three levels of
meaning so at the bottom level we have
words and the meanings of words and
that's the province of lexical semantics
then at the next level we can look at
how the meanings of words combine to
form the meanings of phrases and clauses
and sentences and that's the province of
compositional semantics and then at the
highest level we can look at the meaning
of language in context and the meaning
of dialogues and discourses and this
brings in topics like reference
resolution and pragmatics and so on a
different way to cover up the field of
NLU is to try to categorize tasks based
on the kinds of output representation
that we're trying to produce in most NLU
tasks we take a sample of text as input
and we're trying to map it into some
kind of representation of meaning either
as an output or as an intermediate step
toward a practical goal those semantic
representations can be continuous or
they can be discrete and they can be
simple or they can be complex so for
example in sentiment analysis we're most
commonly trying to generate a scalar
value indicating positive or negative
sentiment it might be just minus 1 or
plus 1 or it might be a five star rating
system or something like that with
vector space models of meaning that
we'll start looking at on Wednesday we
represent the meaning of a word or a
phrase as a point in some high
dimensional space or a different
perspective is that it's some kind of
distribution for example a probability
distribution over abstract topics so
those are continuous representations of
meaning we can also have discrete
representations of meaning so for
example in relation extraction we're
trying to produce relation instances or
database triples things like Larry Page
founder Google or Google located in
Mountain View and in semantic parsing
we're trying to produce semantic
representations that can have
arbitrarily complex logical forms so
here's a logical form that's intended to
denote the largest state and we'll look
at all four kinds of problems in this
class two themes that will appear again
and again in this class one theme is
semantic composition and the question
here is how are the meanings of bigger
pieces like phrases and sentences built
up from the meanings of smaller pieces
like words within the width in
linguistics this question has been a
focal point of compositional semantics
for decades and it will be a big theme
when we look at semantic parsing in a
few weeks but in recent years as vector
space models of meaning have grown in
popularity there's also been a lot of
interesting work on how to
buying vector representations of meaning
and we'll look at some of that work the
other big theme is learning and here the
question is how can we build models of
semantics for semantic interpretation
automatically from data and there are
two reasons for wanting to do this one
is a matter of principle and the other
of pragmatics the principled reason is
that we want to be empiricists we want
to be data-driven and we want to build
models that can interpret the language
that people actually use not the
language that we imagine that they use
the pragmatic reason is that building
large complex models by hand is slow and
tedious and expensive and it doesn't
scale so we want to automate that work
so that we can build these models
quickly and cheaply and by the way also
build them in 40 different languages now
we have some goals for this course that
go beyond just covering the material one
is that we want to give you the skills
and tools that you need to be to quickly
apply that you can quickly apply to nou
problems beyond this class whether in
academic research or in internships or
jobs in industry I mentioned earlier
that there's a there's a voracious
demand for smart people with knowledge
of NLU and we want to enable you to jump
in and be effective wherever you go
another goal is to support you in
completing a project that is worthy of
presentation at a top NLP conference the
biggest deliverable of the class will be
an independent research project and a
final paper in the style of NLP
conference papers in previous years many
cs2 24u papers have actually been turned
into conference papers and whether
you're an undergrad or a master student
or a PhD student presenting a paper at a
top research conference is one of the
best ways to enhance your credentials
and get to the next level so I'm going
to stop here and I'm going to turn
things over to Chris to talk about
course logistics
sure alright great so I'm just gonna
take the remaining 20 or so minutes that
we've got to talk about some course
logistics I want to make sure that you
leave here with a good sense for how the
course will work what kinds of work
you'll be doing and so forth and I
thought a good way to start with this is
to just show you how the regular
assignments are going to unfold as bill
said essentially everything about this
course is geared toward giving you
hands-on experience with the kinds of
models that we're exploring what we
would like for you to do is take like
baseline code that we've implemented and
take it much further and we think that a
key aspect of doing that is that
hands-on experience not just listening
to us talk about these models and
showing off the best results in the
field but rather down nitty gritty
actually exploring the code trying
different simulations out and seeing
what happens and so a lot of what we do
is oriented toward giving you that kind
of hands-on experience and the one way
you can see that is the way we've
structured these assignments so there
are four assignments that they unfold
over the first half of the course the
first one you have two weeks because the
start of the quarter is always kind of
chaotic but after that they go on a
one-week cadence Monday to Monday the
first one is due on April 15 as I said
and their weekly after that each one is
hands-on experience what you'll what
you'll do is work inside a Jupiter
notebook upload it to canvas and we'll
evaluate it but the primary thing beyond
the evaluation is that we want you to to
explore different kinds of models and
the assignment questions are oriented
essentially toward having you set up
some baselines and then a crucial part
of the assignment here is that each one
culminates in what we call a bake-off
this is a term from the field the idea
is that you enter an original system and
it's evaluated on some test data that
we're going to provide during the
bake-off and you enter your score and
we're going to give a little bit of
extra credit to the the teams that have
the top system and the way the
assignments work is you set up those
baselines then you implement your
original system
and you get nine points for doing that
and then you get an additional point if
you just enter the bake-off so you all
you have to do is enter your system and
that happens Monday to wednesday after
the assignment is due and the idea you
know best practices in the field is you
do all your development until you submit
the assignment and then you don't do any
more tuning or anything like that you
just enter your system into the bake-off
and then winning systems get a little
bit of extra credit what we're trying to
do here with these assignments and the
Bake off's is kind of give you a sense
for how we think projects should unfold
because what we're going to push for you
in the second half of the course is that
your project should kind of implement
some baseline systems and then offer an
original system that tests a hypothesis
about how you think the world works a
scientific hypothesis and we're trying
to push you in that direction get you to
build those baselines and then doing do
something original and the bake-off
aspect of this is meant to be just kind
of fun and what we'll do is reflect back
to you which systems one which system
does really poorly and try to offer
insights as to why that happened and
that's always been really interesting
because this is like crowdsourcing lots
of different ways that you might
approach these problems some good some
bad and I think we can all learn from
the results what we're trying to do as I
said is kind of exemplify best practices
for NLU the code that we offer is meant
to do that the assignments are meant to
push you in that direction you should
let us know if you think we're not
living up to this we would love to have
an exchange with you about how to do
better when it comes to best practices
for solving these problems so that's
kind of the first half of the course and
you'll see that when we look at the
webpage you'll see that what we're doing
as part of that is introducing lots of
topics and there are the topics that we
think of is the kind of essence of NLU
the ones that if you really master them
and you can do pretty much anything in
the field and that's just we have
limited time but we're hoping that
that's kind of a generator for you for
lots of different approaches and
problems this is a practical note here
for the assignments and for the projects
and the Bake off's you can work in teams
the way you'll do this is you should
form a team on canvas and I've given
instructions here you go to the people
tab and then the groups tab and then you
have to pick a pre-selected team from
the large number of teams that I created
for each one of these assignments
that's a little bit tedious but once
you've formed your team that means one
of you can submit the work and it will
be you'll all get credit for it and you
should make sure that if you form the
group then your assignment is associated
with your group
I think the interface is pretty clear
there so the only tedious part is
actually forming a group because you
have to pick from a pre-selected one
that was the best I could figure out but
in terms of actually your work being
uploaded to canvas it's just that you'll
upload a Jupiter notebook and then the
team will take it and evaluate it did
you have a question there can be yeah
that's the way I set it up you'll see
that they're called like assign one
bake-off one assigned to bake-off two
that means you can switch there's also
one two one for the final projects if
you want to have the same team through
all of them you'll just have to
reconstitute your team for each one it's
not the best system but I think if we
get used to it or it'll work okay
questions about the assignments and the
bake-offs before I move on yeah I'll
show you when we look at the website in
a little bit we have slightly different
criteria for large teams working on the
projects but it's a very soft touch
thing yeah but for these I don't know
what we're hoping that you have a fun
experience of collaborating and you
yourself can try lots more models if you
work in a team and see what works best
then the second half of the course
you'll see this when we look at the
schedule like the first half is topics
and then the second half is less about
topics and more about us trying to help
you successfully execute on a high
quality and LU project and so what we do
is shift toward lectures that are much
more about metrics and methods and kick
tricks and tips and other best practices
things that will help push your project
in better directions so it becomes less
about introducing new content and more
about that kind of methodological stuff
and we're hoping that in parallel with
that of course you're working on your
project as a team and the way we're
going to encourage that to happen is
that it kind of the project unfolds over
a series of assignments so the first one
is a lit review this is just kind of you
and your team if you
getting oriented around what problem you
want to solve may be less familiar what
we've done is set up an experimental
protocol as the second assignment and
I'll show you what it what its contents
are when we go to the web page but the
idea here is just that we're trying to
push you to be sure that your project is
testing some scientific hypotheses then
you do a video presentation we haven't
typically done poster sessions because
it seems like an awful lot of work to
create a poster when this class was much
smaller back when NL was much less
popular we would have people give
3-minute talks and that was always lots
of fun because we saw all these
wonderful little presentations the class
has gotten too big for that so as a
compromise what we've done in recent
years is have teams do little short
videos and then you could put them on
YouTube or upload them to canvas and it
can be public or private whatever you
want to do but the point is that gives
us a glimpse of what your project is
like and gives you a first chance to
think about how you want to present it
and then of course the final thing is
the final paper and if you're interested
to get started here this is a link we'll
post the slides in a bit a link to some
past projects that are really
exceptional from a bunch of different
years and from recent years I have some
video links available on so you could
also see what good video presentations
were like questions about that I'm going
to circle back to this in a second but
yeah go ahead that would be wonderful
yeah of course yeah I don't want to make
it a formal requirement but one of the
the best things about NLP in general and
this is sort of true of all of AI at
this point is how much the community has
formed norms around making sure that you
open-source your code and data it's
almost like you don't have results if
you don't have results that other people
can pretty easily reproduce and this is
wonderful because when I started out in
the field you would spend months or
years trying to build up baselines that
other people had established and now the
pace is picking up just because it's so
easy to share these results and that
kind of comes back to people's
willingness to distribute data
away and also open source territory so
not a requirement but it would be great
to beginning like github links for all
these projects other questions
of course logistics so I'm going to go
follow these links in a second here but
so I'm going to go to the website the
teaching team is me and Bill and we have
10 TAS I was wondering and this is gonna
be hard because of the microphones but
because the TAS who are here stand up I
would love it if you introduce yourself
and just said kind of what your
interests are and NLU and also if you're
an alum of the course it would be cool
to mention that wanna start Student
Success Department I haven't won in the
course and my interest in Lu is nothing
in particular I am I'm also a master's
student I took this last spring
it's my interest in Lu are you know
generally building systems to understand
like language of the Internet in English
and also other languages and everything
else master student thank you because
last year
am i interested mostly in dialogue and
conversation systems I'm also a master
student and my main interest is natural
language inference and I did take this
class the students - sorry the important
domain controller is having satellites
in Australian each incretins 20 person
not sure who's missing well trying to
interview spots people next class and
after that if you want to mention it who
can't be here in person he's one of the
TAS he's going to be more or less of
virtual TA so he graduated from Stanford
a number of years ago he did his
master's thesis and his honours work in
naturally with understanding kind of
applied to social problems and he's
returning this is a program that was
created by SCPD so it should be fun to
interact with him because he's been an
industry doing I know you type things
now for a number of years and I think
you'll be able to reach him on the video
oh and I wanted to say also thinking
about these alums and I remember some of
their projects one of the wonderful
things about this course is that we get
a really wide range of projects they
kind of go from yeah like hard core deep
learning things all the way through to
digital humanities and kind of social
science problems and that's a wonderful
aspect of this course for me because
like for me as a researcher one of the
exciting things I think I can do is
identify results that come out of NLP
and show people in neighboring fields
especially my own field of linguistics
that they have real value and it's just
great to see people doing projects that
kind of exemplify that in sociology and
in history and in English and in
psychology and linguistics of course and
so we're very encouraging about getting
really creative about the kind of
problem that you've taken for your final
project the lectures for the course will
be streamed and stored on canvas you
should all have access to canvas if you
want to reach the staff this is the
address to do that but you can also just
post on Piazza we I think the whole
teaching team will be quite active on
Piazza so you can use that to get in
touch with us and then here's a link
which I'll show you in a second just the
kind of things that make up the core
components for the grade before I switch
out of these slides special announcement
we have a special session on Friday it's
going to be run by Lucy and Ashton that
is about its kind of refresher or to
help you get up to speed on Python and
I'm working in Jupiter notebooks we're
kind of assuming that you're a pretty
good Python programmer already the
Jupiter notebook thing might be more
unfamiliar to you but it's going to be a
kind of norm in the course that we do a
lot of our coding and exploration and
assignments and bake-offs and stuff in
notebooks so if that's new to you I
highly encourage you to go to this
Friday session and here are the details
well give you a bunch of other reminders
for this it's great that Lucy and Ashwin
are doing this and then for next time
you should get your computing
environment set up I'll show you in a
second what I mean by that but here's
the kind of rundown we have a course
github repository that has lots of code
it has the notebooks it has the
assignments you should get in the habit
of kind of syncing with that repository
making sure you have the latest updates
and so forth
a lot of the tools are there and this is
a kind of rundown we're gonna encourage
you to use anaconda for your Python
environment officially the course is
using Python 3.7 I have tested the code
all the way down to 3.5 and it actually
basically works under Python - please do
not use Python - so now moribund
but if you're stuck on 3.5 for some
reason and you don't want to create a
virtual environment you're probably
going to be ok and then there's a bunch
of other stuff that you want to install
a lot of this is taken care of if you're
using anaconda but if not you're gonna
have to kind of do all the requirements
and then there's a huge data
distribution folder I just updated the
link to one where I think the archive is
gonna work I was really proud of myself
for getting all of the data for the
whole quarter together into one archive
and of course it was like too big to be
a zip archive I'll post some corrected
links and with luck we'll get this
sorted out but you only have to get it
downloaded once
and then what you should do for the next
time and kind of over the next couple of
weeks is watch the screencast that we
have available for this unit I would say
the core reading is the one that's by
attorney and Pentel 2010 and then you
should just start exploring the note
books and you could do that kind of on
your own speed I'm gonna be here with
you giving lectures about it and the
lectures are also going to be trying to
get you to work on your laptop or or
less as I talked to explore things and
figure out what's going on let me just
show you a bit about the website in the
remaining time that we have okay so this
is the main page it has pretty much
everything you want so there's a link to
the piazza site which you should join if
you're not already enrolled there and
the canvas site and our github and
there's the staff address and then down
the left column here you have the
teaching team and we've listed all of
our office hours so that's kind of
organizational stuff and then here's
where all the action is going to be so
this is the main schedule it goes kind
of topic by topic so as bill said we're
going to do vector space models that is
vector representations of meaning for
the first two weeks it's kind of slow
start as people get oriented and we you
know kind of get people who are newer to
the field up to speed and that covers
homework one and bake-off one and then
we do some supervised sentiment analysis
using the Stanford sentiment treatment
than relation extraction the natural
language inference grounded language
understanding and semantic parsing and I
believe that's the kind of kind of the
point where we shift the assignments
become more project oriented and the
topics are more around like metrics and
methods contextual word representations
as a tool to make your models even
better and some other stuff like writing
up and presenting your work and I'm I'm
not sure if the scheduling yet but I'm
hoping that on May 22 we have a kind of
panel discussion with people who have
been doing NLU in industry for a while
to kind of give you guys a sense for
what it's like to take this research and
apply it out there in the world
and then and more kind of project stuff
the last the last part of the week of
the course because of Knakal when a lot
of people have to be a way is kind of
just given over to you for doing project
work and then the final project is due
on June 9 another thing about this
schedule so there are a lot of links
already in place those are the notebooks
for the assignments and the kind of core
notebooks that will allow you to do the
hands-on work that we're envisioning
that will help you do the assignments
and get really accustomed to what these
tools are like so those are already
there and you can start to work with
them and you might want to skip around
especially if you're familiar with NLU
problems like you took the deep learning
course or something like that you might
want to skip around because for example
you could do a really good job on the
bake-off if you can figure out those
contextual word representations that
kind of thing so browse around see
what's there we'll be posting slideshows
pretty regularly that kind of try to
integrate all this material together
along the resources column we have links
to recommended readings and in some
cases those screencasts which are short
YouTube videos that I made that are kind
of encapsulations of the really
technical parts of the material that
we'll be covering the stuff that's kind
of hard to just get from a lecture that
you hear once i've tried to distill it
down to just the essence we have a
specially good coverage for those for
these early units which is good because
in this first unit for vector space
models we're really trying to build a
foundation for thinking about how to
build up more complex and LU systems
that's it for now any questions oh yeah
I could show you just one more thing so
the other two pages are we have a
detailed description of how the projects
unfold all the requirements are here for
like what we expect from a lit review
what we expect from that experimental
protocol is some guidance about video
presentations and the final paper and
here are those links to past
objects that are really exceptional in
case you want some example so the range
of projects people have explored and
also just what really good projects look
like and then finally just in this last
minute there's also a kind of policies
and requirements page that reviews like
how much homeworks are do it worth the
lit review the protocol the
presentations and the final projects and
there's some details here about kind of
policies and other stuff like that I
guess I'll leave it to you to read that
on your own it's not so thrilling for me
to review it now before we wrap up are
there any questions or comments or
concerns that I could feel it yes the
bake-off isn't just determined by the
accuracy or other picture for each one
we've specified the criteria there's a
specific score typically and what I've
said is that the systems that have the
top score will get the extra credit
we're gonna have to see what the range
of scores is like put it's very tightly
regimented the way these things test
yeah I'm working on it trying to get a
sure I have to be a little persistent I
guess but I am hoping that